[Music]
[Music]
hello happy Thursday happy sort of Cod
launch day in a way it'll be launching
for the most of the rest of the world by
9 p.m. tonight but for us we have it a
little bit early and as somebody had
mentioned earlier yes a lot of there's a
good amount of people that have it early
because you know there's a you know
across the world this is a new map by
the way we should just I should get in
into this real quick you're good
Oh what what's up oh you see a nice hot
car for hot Rob Kropp yeah this is a new
map I've never seen this one at least
yeah I want to just kick this off by
letting people know that you know we
have not whoop that guy we have not been
playing this much like this is literal
that was the first kill I've literally
had nice yeah I played the warm-up match
yeah we're just we're just diving in for
the first time so you know well we both
played the multiplayer beta though and
we're definitely nice kill we're
definitely trying to get to level 4
we're only level 2 because level 4 is
when you know that's that's not a
grenade remember you're specialists do
have abilities if you want grenade
you're gonna have to go battery she's
got the cluster grenade which is really
good especially in certain modes not
sure how good it's gonna be for Kill
Confirmed which is what we're playing
but we both did played the multiplayer
beta we also wanted to play some
blackout today but I don't think I'd be
any people in the lobby yeah I think
because I'm not gonna have the majority
of people don't have the game yet that
that is not gonna be a doable thing
right now yeah I mean that's that's kind
of the reasoning behind battle royale
right like why it works is because you
can so quickly and effortlessly get into
another match but was not a player base
to to be grounded with like you just not
playing it so that's how everyone seems
to be like we got in there were nine
people there were nine people and then
there were like five because
we're just going in and then another
leaving they're everywhere
but yeah during the beta for the
blackout beta rather it was pretty
seamless we got in and out of matches
pretty quickly so curious to see by
tonight if you know how that shapes out
yeah well you show zombies ass crime
yeah yeah because we can't do blackout
we'll probably do like a 2/3 1/3 thing
where we play you know roughly 2/3 of
the time we'll spend in just okay I
guess you joined mid match will play
just traditional cod multiplayer get
through some specialists see you know
who you guys want to check out even
though most of them are probably pretty
known by now and then we'll do some
zombies we can even close
split-screen if we want I brought a
controller in just in case and then
there's a new zombie Rush mode I think
that Callie and Aaron we're talking
about that's not so puzzle based and
it's more just like horde based you just
kill stuff you do still put up you know
your walls and things like that and you
still are kind of unlocking doors but
it's a little bit more arcadey and not
so much like figuring out the easter egg
right right like trial and error which I
actually and excited to see because
that's how I have always kind of liked
cod is when I like you know you get into
the rhythm you know what you're doing
you're just trying to survive opposed to
like yeah spending around like alright
let's just try to do this let's see if
this yeah switch what's up Dalton how
are you doing I see you thanks everyone
for tuning and of course taking spot
live we're live Monday to Friday at 11
a.m. Pacific actually we're gonna go a
little earlier today but we had some
meetings and stuff like that so it
worked out actually that we're on our
set time so come back sub if you haven't
and yeah is that review in progress
today or tomorrow or forget it today
today so stay tuned for that one review
in progress will be up later today just
because as the servers go live we don't
want to give a final review until we're
really tested you know all that
functionality the connectivity even in
our example right now like not really
being able
i black out right how can you even score
a game a third of the game right so for
sure we definitely want to do our due
diligence of course but expect a review
in progress for sure and yeah we can try
again crime but to hop in a blackout and
show you just kind of like where where
that state of things is but I tried a
little bit earlier I had like nine
people and my like Lobby you know when
you dive down to the map pre actual game
not enough and then six or seven just
now before the stream when Rob hopped in
so it's it kind of expected though
because technically it doesn't release
hell like 9:00 p.m. tonight and that's
when you should really see an influx of
players I would assume but yeah also the
interesting thing is we've queued for
TDM but at some point it just goes you
know what there's more people playing
Kill Confirmed we're gonna put you in
there which is fine I think at least for
now yeah just so we can get in some
games of course Dalton we will play some
zombies we can try the new rush mode and
then also try like the tribute more
traditional like I think I have to story
type based ones this time around let's
say you can yeah there's there is a lot
of zombies this time around him pelican
mafia are there any easter eggs not sure
I haven't dove into it outside of the
beta that I played yeah don't worry
Martin I mean we'll get there we're
getting there
we only need to one more play it now we
need to because someone left dang there
that guy is 20 he must have been so it
went kind of like when I live you know
what live at 6 alright technically we
kind of had it yesterday but I I don't
know what time the servers went live
last night I know that we could start
streaming at 6 a.m. here we go we got a
match now yep oh sorry
day day I'm sure there's call of duty
zombies Easter eggs I wasn't sure if he
was just asking a general question of
like Easter eggs
I haven't played enough of the zombies
myself either to to tell you what those
Easter eggs are yeah how could you have
not played any Cod's I played a lot of
God's more than I want to
the vault which I guess who's your go-to
specialists I don't know who's the
hottest I don't know it depends on the
the game type you're playing I think TDM
is it's kind of in my opinion throws
some of the specialist abilities kind of
out the window a little bit they're not
as useful words when you play some of
the more tactical mm game types yeah
like let's say like a control point or
like you know defend the defend the
points kind of thing like torx really
good just because he's got area-denial
with the barbed wire which is super
frustrating to deal with and then also
the barriers which are also really good
I think a TDM it's more just like you
know maybe either having recon for the
kind of like sonar pulse Allah Hanzo to
kind of reveal the map is good and also
I think your battery battery's good just
because she's got you know grenade
launcher for super she has just your
traditional grenade which is also good
you know come on almost I was gonna say
the old Crouch tick the title says
gameplay live yeah that's true I might
be leaving this room very angry like I
said if you if we have to switch off so
that you kind of do some ten finger
breathing we can do that as well
I'll take some shame oh he's stuck man I
maybe had like turn my sensitivity to up
too high a little bit I'm like there you
go alright level three which is good
watch out for that mesh mine backseat
gaming at its finest there's one on the
other side too damn it okay excuse me
to say just add oh yeah back to standard
five five no it's I think four standard
okay yeah you didn't get to warm up so
this is like almost essentially your
warmup match like I was joking with you
earlier when I was struggling I was like
dude I don't have my adderall help me
I prefer crack that gets me real into it
I believe there's like 15 or 16
multiplayer maps
frequency contraband seaside payload
Hacienda gridlock Arsenal icebreaker
Morocco militia jungle slums firing
arranged summits so looks like 14 give
or take yeah see that was a good example
of like the health regen system there
right like you knew that you probably
weren't gonna get to heel off and to
kill so you just went for the double
kill so that's the other big thing if
you guys didn't know is it's not just
like your traditional regen of health
you actually have to use but yeah we're
fighting on ps4 pro not playing on PC
right now just F quiet clean kill
I like the health regen
apparently crime says you can play it by
switching regions that seems pretty
smart actually what the hell was that
had forks fire flamethrower where was
that's work
sorry plane break for fire break oh my
god
I'm sorry put your dog on a leash that's
my go to Joe Dalton Nance wants to know
Rob what was your favorite zombies map
um yeah blackout first cheese black
black ops 2 that guy's got that night
skin alright so I fell off zombies and I
mean even cod for that matter like one
should I love a little older war zombies
Wow
so I would I liked not dereyes but like
the one with the up I am actually
excited to play this tonight I'm gonna
see if any of my friends are gonna hop
on give me a good break off of destiny
that's unfortunate
so that's it I don't get that grenade
launcher huh nope you used it I got two
good names I sure did yeah
here she's got spam it hilarious
you don't go prone in multiplayer dude
hey do you do like that well sometimes
when you're when you're one be wanting
if you if I don't have the I don't have
the good reactions anymore but people
that just do the insta prone or go prone
while they're shooting you usually will
win because you're still aiming high and
they're dropping down
also once we hit level 4 it'll be a
little bit easier for us we'll do a
little bit better I feel like because
armor is very well I'm very good kind of
strong it's it's good especially early
on when people are starting off because
it gives you that little extra buffer so
yeah are you guys gonna play blackouts
his commander Jane Shepard we're gonna
we can try but earlier we tried and
nobody was really cueing out for it so I
think that it's gonna just take some
time to get there
I really like this site the that site is
really good I like it a little blue dot
one you don't crouch or lay you take it
as a man
yeah I am excited for blackout
unfortunately there are not enough
people to be playing that well Scott um
yeah there's no campaign I heard like
there's some specialist stuff that you
can do that's like I'm like a campaign
light almost almost like what titanfall
the original time fall kind of did I
haven't tried it I don't even know if
that's the right computer I have not
seen that yeah I haven't seen it either
but so it's like it just it seems like a
so you have all these specialists right
it just seems like a bunch of like
equivalent to you could say overwatch in
like there are YouTube videos of just
like oh it's door back stories and
that's what I think it is it's just like
a bunch of videos on each of these
specialists okay that's what I I'm led
to believe how does the healing thing
work so what it is is you have a ability
or cooldown on every specialist it's
tied to you when you hit l1 it'll give
you health back but it it slowly ticks
back up and then you can't spam it
because it's on a cool-down so you know
you have to choose when to do it when
when not to do it it's kind of like
Rainbow six siege a little bit I guess
as commander James Sheppard said so that
was fire break is the name of the person
with the flamethrower ruin is the one of
the ground-pound kind of like tighten
the Titan from destiny too he also has
the grappling which allows you to kind
of like traverse and also try to do sick
plays 9 bang is actually really strong
I'm just not good with a Jax's shield
super
profit is profit he has the shock a
super rifle and then he also has the
little thing that I call a Roomba even
though it's like a seeker go jump it'll
kind of roll around and then shock one
of the opponents yeah crash is pretty
traditional he gives you over shield or
like more health to everyone and then
also will give the assault pack which
gives like more ammo and nice guys oh
we're on the same map because I guess
these people love this map this is an
old one right I'm pretty sure this is a
classic kind of redone it's got a
full-on Mattox oh yeah nothing hold on
you gotta let it let it do its thing
it's more it turns into smaller creator
risky risky business risking
game about to be lit gents can't wait
this Paul Jones yeah I'm excited
like I had a good time with blackout I
don't know how many my friends
I mean outside the office enjoyed it but
I'm sure it will have some sessions in
the office where I don't know it's fun
time still I think because like when the
the multiplayer beta for blackout was
out you know we would squad up at the
end of the day play play a few matches
and I thought we have it we want a
couple which is fun obviously Jesus or
you got points for Italy's there's
blackout rank you up in multiplayer I
don't believe so dab tcp THD because it
looked like it had a different level up
system they seemed very separate yep yep
I'm trying my best to stay up on
comments apologies as its kind of kind
of hot and heavy and I'm trying to watch
Rob play a little bit but I will do a
better job or I'll try to Big Mike how
do you get this early we have like
basically review coffee I want to change
my class change okay well the thing is
if you change your class now you're
gonna lose the progression to your super
that you had but you could you totally
could but you are halfway there so what
I do is kind of like overwatch you want
to use that super ability basically
after and then switch would be my advice
you yup clean that up let them do the
the damage and then you clean up and
kill steal Oh yep great nice I'm pretty
sure this is an old school maps um I
remember I kind of remember this one it
looks a little familiar yeah cuz I
remember that fountain area in the
middle yeah so how did you so how do you
guys get dis early cuz my any digital
copies are locked yeah so we have a disc
version that's how we're playing wow
guys got full-on GS k this is a good
time Rob in the future when you can to
steal other people's like really loaded
guns oh he's got a retell aport er there
like this gun like the ones with like
four attachments yeah that one oh you're
almost at a kill streak nice alright you
have you a B which is really good for
you team obviously you hold it you hold
hold triangle there you go
they're spawning behind or like in front
of you sorry yeah yeah as in they like
flipped with you oh yes okay they're all
over there yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you can hellstorm home too you got to
hold it but you got to do it again
you got a r18 oh that's fine at work you
can cluster missile that one but it's
fine it all worked out didn't matter
can't believe I didn't die you're good
good wow that one well almost a
helicopter too which would be really
good obviously it's no pressure
my heart just skipped kick the Oh put
your dog on a leash oh that sucks that
does so it's a streak in their damn
house this night it's not being a
quickscoping a thing I believe you can
quickscope bullish bullish sorry if I
butchered your name there that guy did
it to rob a couple times forget the guys
name in this in this lobby but it worked
pretty well in the beta as well think
your level four should be able to
hopefully make a class here whoo helps
fun gothic cannon we just have a early
diss copy at grenade launchers dope yeah
it's really good too in certain like
control like control point types game
you know it's because you can just
they're all trying to like sit on it and
you can just dump the whole clip or
whatever yeah nice fun pretty good I
enjoyed it for sure
Robby's in great hopper mode yeah that's
true so for gaming stream that's I'm
glad you caught him if that was the case
that sucks if he tried to do yeah so hit
done what someone tried to steal his
like black ops four mystery box edition
oh he done though and then go to oh wait
you're still locked I thought it was for
that you could maybe they update that's
weird where does it say it's on the
bottom-left create-a-class no where does
it say like what you need to be
I tried hovering over it I can't now I
can I'm trying not to use the sounds
like honey stick the way you should it's
good you good system it is maybe it's
five maybe it's at five there is a
single player for specialist yeah Ryan
fro it's kind of like backstory for some
of the specialists it's not all of them
have they been winning uh 5050 maybe so
far Bob I can't was a second yeah if it
is something like that what's up with
story mode ask Anthony Reid we can check
that out later it's pretty much like
these light tutorials for certain
specialist and then you get a little bit
of more information about their
background and stuff like that yeah like
I don't know I think I think there is
some misinformation saying that it's
story or like it's a campaign it's like
I'm hearing that a little bit it's not
do not get your hopes up cyber ninja 16
says is it worth the price of a mission
with no singleplayer cyber ninja for me
personally um I uh I almost always
gravitated to the multiplayer for COD
and I didn't really play the
single-player so for me it's not as big
of a deal that it doesn't have a
campaign but that's me right like some
people enjoyed it I'm I've said this on
every college team I'm curious the
percentage of people that play Cod that
actually go through this the whole
single-player it must not have been that
big for them to get what they've they've
done which is like go with a more
multiplayer heavy game right yeah
this is one of the maps from the beta's
I like this map Oh close the old jump
shot the old he's a jumper and jump
shots pretty good that's why I'm not
good at it but I'm gonna go this way
yeah actually there's a guy here do you
think Cod will be battlefield 5 I have
that's hard to say
doctor goodness I'm sure we'll have a
vs. episode on it but battlefield 5
doesn't come out for like another month
because they delayed it's like from the
25 October to November yeah so they're
like end of November now yeah don't
forget you have your seeker so what's up
with this thing so it'll kind of roam
around the map and if you find somebody
it'll shock them and unless their
teammates
free them you should have a free kill or
your teammates should ever free kill
like right now it's stunning someone oh
close I think the other guy got to kill
for you though so you got like an assist
for it
Alex Fitch says all caught games are the
same I mean they play the same I would
say blackout is new just because it's a
battle royale it's a new mode for them
and for them to deuce a map as big as
they did compared to like a lot of the
stuff they normally do they did a pretty
good job but you know obviously somewhat
at the price of campaign but like I said
there's still some backstory stuff which
we could check out in a little bit just
to see what that's like
I heard there's cutscenes for that so
there's still something they're just not
your full-on you know traditional
campaign like some people might may have
wanted there's always someone else you
got to always be moving especially in
TDM that's why TDM is a little bit it
can be a little bit more frustrating if
you're if you're not like a crazy Slayer
as as they would say slay out only
because you know it's just you versus
the the other people whereas some of the
other multiplayer modes again I think
those actually are better to for this
just in terms of the specialist
abilities but those give you more of a
sense of like oh I need to maintain this
point or I need to capture any point so
it gives you more objective based gaming
whereas this is just you know guess
layout how do you all have early asked
it access says Cedric you know we're
GameSpot we are a news review site so we
have a review copy that's how we have it
early so yeah but game will launch in
was that like
I think it's 9 p.m. Pacific so about
nine and a half hours that's why when
I'll be starting on my own
cool so you need to shoot that or hope
someone on your team shoots it you still
cut kind of can shoot like or just die
you can shoot terribly because you're
free your hands still kind of doing it
but you won't be able to really aim well
of course I'm a taste of their own
medicine
go my son what wrong way kind of just
goes where it wants there no he's near
shocking see easy kill there's another
one to the left do that jump shot is
that it that's the cool that's what all
the kids are doing
yeah well be holding you you were there
so he's gonna jump the corner and just
start pre firing I'm not good at it so I
generally oh yeah someone on the other
team is popping off
cluster what's his uh special again
rucking what is a si stand for they
basically said that he said that they're
selling it like three hours ago so they
get the game a little earlier so it's
like the old special where you basically
get a rifle and that rifle will shock
people and if there's more people it'll
chain to them and there get debilitating
or knock down so okay that's what it
does it's kind of a skill-based thing
because if you shoot it and it it's not
it's not like you can't spam it
necessarily but you know if you're
fighting someone you miss your first
shot you're probably gonna die but it's
it can be very devastating if you wind
it what that guy's got a Maddox he's
been playing a bit or he's running a
class that we don't know about watch out
for that I don't know if that one's
yours or not see this is a way that tor
can die even a guy the thing has a lot
of weight who should you sweetie
shouldn't it break it yeah man I'm
killing it oh I see that guy yeah it's
not the smartest sometimes oh wow you
guys still want this wait
I feel like getting rekt by Barney over
there
hopefully oh maybe because this guy's
reckon you got Titan I think the time
got buffed at the end of the last cycle
so saw a couple people using it so let's
be decent
alright should we there are mosh pit
modes James but yeah Rafi's doing good
team Carrie I want to play already says
Angelo yeah class warming up ooh game a
sec I'll create a class do it so yeah
okay I don't want it that's fine jump in
a ting so you're obviously not gonna
have access to all the weapons so where
do you think you wanna we got the pick
10 system of course there's an upsetting
lack of shotguns here Erik no no it's a
secondary oh yeah which you don't have
you have 12 all eight okay
and you can't level that up I think it's
them I think it's the log that you can
level it to the point where you when you
hit with it they can't heal for like
eliminated or a set amount of time which
is pretty good
were you running stims Simmons Tim shot
a lot was that you or was that Aaron I
can't remember it cuz I I use body armor
so that's where you would put your body
armor on which will give you a better
chance but you got a level two six
but yeah cuz it'll let you absorb some
shots to the body instead of just
getting absolutely melted so you just
gotta get another level which we do you
either keep playing multiplayer or you
check out that specialist thing so it's
up to you it's up to me yes pressure
alright well let's back out if you want
to check out the specialist let's go
check out the special so there's a
specialist HQ this guy screaming it's
ruined ruined he's in the easin war man
yeah yeah that's fine whatever
alright alright here you go have a
cutscene I'll go full game
we wanted to make the world a better
place
I chose to do it from a lab and a
boardroom
but Jessica wanted to fight happy
birthday mommy
you have a beautiful heart Lucy just
like your mother
and that's what got her killed
feel like that must be battery
there's ruin got bleeding-edge
very organized oh oh there goes her arm
Lucy you will live to see a better world
oh there goes her other arm he died what
forearm oh how she not Oh her mouth oh
gosh this is good I miss her every day
your mom was uh she was very brave just
like her until we
they're needy can
feel like one Owens got a good battery
or that will look like battery she must
have liked robotic arms now there's
recon property at this condo in a pile
of dead bodies lighten up she's the real
deal
what are we getting into a hobby show me
what she's paying anything she asked for
me Trillian are there's torque [ __ ]
doesn't exist
no man she's planning some battle more
like a war in cash and portable [ __ ]
I'm thinking bigger than battles and
Wars I brought you here to change the
world as the Avengers what do you have
in mind
alright so where are the Avengers the
military version so play sure I guess
you're gonna learn about Ajax's
background story or you could switch
which batch whatever it's fine
welcome to the immersion your instructor
has been activated
great his methods are unconventional and
often nuanced but if you want to fight
in very numbers better be goddamn good
oh snap oh whoa sergeant Frank Woods
would look like hammered [ __ ] it's all
on your mind Mason the real world I'm
pretty get the hell out of here I got
this that's a simulation
all right our trainer my name's woods
friend of the family
you don't know who I am top [ __ ] I don't
know who you are you will all right
here's your deal you come equipped
special issue weapons and gear I will
train you up and get you squared away
now maybe you feeling frosty want to get
right into the [ __ ] fine by me
select combat immersion often mix it up
with the bots come on pick something
either way okay
let me do it what a badass
alright just smoking that cigarette
reminds me of my dad wait benign bang
grenade the more you cook it the more
times it goes boom stuns and blinds the
enemy interesting ballistic shield comes
with a gun slot and transforms for extra
cover it's tough as nails
no chance that it's not a BFF first name
nine last name bang so it's not a
campaign it's like background story for
some of the specialists so it's also a
tutorial as you can see it goes bang
yeah so it's teaching us how a Jackson
that dirtbag I like it's a fake blind
like plant egg temporary vision
alright let's cook a banger - level
three level three that cook it yeah I
would love to do level three to go it's
really strong actually at level three
it's like I can't even kill the AI quick
enough I'm so good yeah yeah get them
around the corner the old bank shot [ __ ]
happens when you do you deploy the
shield no big deal your shields been
deployed but you still dance dance baby
you are showing big promise buddy thanks
to mount a major melee masterpiece on
this dipwad
Hey ladies each dipwad has what you're
supposed to mail him Oh
all right back to cooking class you can
keep a grenade cooker to all your guests
have arrived
and then you serve it hot
yeah I like this who like this said it
you hold it I thought he was gonna say
set it and forget it you should have you
should have a my throne
yeah yeah
and I'm here manchu tamale stunned
because i scared that o is a woods is
killing it right now is this been
fortify the front of your shoe okay
we're protection but this comes at a
cost
you lose mobility yeah but you get it
you get a five shield free can reach
that room dig this
I got to learn how to use this better
yeah to the nine things will do well I
mean like I my name's like friggin are
loading there too
hey likes a really silly dialogue yeah
yeah sure why not
might as well make a bunch your ass
makes a great room breech combo
[Music]
right that's right take a name Jesus
taking names Rob holding nothing back
scorestreak Rob let's not crow so just
so everyone knows if you look at the
bottom right that shows actually how
much you know you actually have so the
more he's family
yeah get him on this one in just like
cod spawn kill them oh hi
you just head up to the next marker next
marker strike god this RC so it is
pretty much a tutorial yeah
that's why do this all day
hello bad guy Wow which has a party now
let's go put this [ __ ] to use they don't
fit a combat [ __ ] you're gonna take this
later woods more story so we got we had
unlocked this right having done that
probably
[Music]
your weapons and get on the ground
oh this is origin story
with us
[ __ ] you are you with em I'm not with
you yeah piece of [ __ ] get rotten
there you go
all right Team Deathmatch do not
overthink this man just kill the enemy
do it faster if I bought as a team watch
your buddy six you'll be watching yours
so this will teach you to Torrio like
TDM reach the score limit first boom
that's how you win I might bounce out
yeah you want to go back to real
multiplayer we know how multiplayer
change this is associated with so this
is like basically a tutorial but it has
like a long story stuff but it's
intertwined with the specialists like
it's yeah we believe so and it's only
certain specialists I asked Aaron if it
was every specialist and he said it
wasn't all of them so but who knows we
haven't gone through it all so maybe or
maybe he didn't get all right let's
leave all right bring us back host ended
it's a troll you think all the AI
players are like come on dude this
cancels again so that was kind of a
small slice of the specialist stuff if
you're curious I expect you know a few
more of those many cutscenes were as
many as the other specialists that you
can do and all that stuff so what's next
should we try I mean you can try now
it's pretty I'm positive you're not
gonna find a game well luckily be able
to determine pretty quickly yeah like I
should do solo right yeah I think so or
ego the quads goes up to 100 but solos
go up to 88 and so do do is
ragequit yeah we were age quit out of
that didn't want to play some BOTS we
need one more level to get that body
armor and I think things will be a
little smoother but then we're also
gonna have to level up guns and get all
the attachments so that's how it goes
when this bull game come out for the
u.s. I believe 9:00 p.m. tonight which
is 12:00 a.m. Eastern
give me the shadow it was like the model
didn't the video mode style yeah yeah
like just looked like she was just like
covered in mud yeah I think when you
cycle through them pretty quickly the
game can't catch up right away so then
it takes a second so I kind of like pop
back in yeah the numbers look all these
numbers what do they mean so three
people say six six six six if you look
at the top right that's how many people
are trying to queue up and we're stuck
in deployment so we're probably just
gonna back out how are we playing we
have the a physical copy early because
of it's a review copy so yeah so Dom B's
um or a multiplayer another multiplayer
and then we'll do some more multiplayer
yeah and then we'll end on some busy but
you might as well start leveling up when
are your classes though yeah so if you
thought it was rough earlier it's gonna
get rougher here
did you actually hit select it's okay
looks like this wasn't sure okay
so level class you mean so to level up
the class or not level class you're
gonna level up weapons right right um to
get attachments and optics yes exactly
so like whatever gun you think you want
to use that's what we should kind of
work on right now and I'll go with this
yeah okay sure
I see ours pretty solid else I mean what
else you maybe make a second class
that's SMG with the mx-9 emic sign was
really good and they nerfed it in beta
but I'm sure it's still probably pretty
good so switch that out to like the MX 9
and then can you switch the perks switch
that I just leave that that's sucks and
then oh go lightweight I guess we got
pulled blooded yet
and then ghost go ghost so they can see
you and show you it for this one too
you already got ghost the first perk
right now is not so great because we
haven't unlocked anything so it doesn't
really matter as much
gotcha unless you want scavengers fine
though if you want just get more ammo
how does that split screen our guys will
show you guys in a second once we get
this out me that's pretty good
okay what's smg's are always the thing
yeah some of the a ours are pretty good
though Ben so that's why she has this
mask on right was I heard that was not
serif I think oh I think that person
should have died Wow please play what
you want says no assists oh thank you
okay
taya Cod Pro it seems no I just played a
bunch of the beta so I have a decent
idea I remember the days of double
familis so broken yeah homeless was
really good back in the day for sure I
still like the like FAL with like full
auto or whatever that was that's a fun
time to you
ah the drone squad is what we were
getting hunted by earlier we didn't get
to use that or I'd never got to use that
in beta how's the game SPS gamer uh it's
good so far I mean we're only really
able to play kind of the traditional cod
multiplayer and then we did that
specialist headquarters thing and then
we can probably check out these aam be
here in a second we're gonna drop a 40
bomb probably not Oscar I mean I'd like
us to drop a 20 bomb is that fine
is there a hardcore mode for you guys I
didn't check it's there is hardcore mode
look like I thought I think the tough
part is not everyone has the game yet
obviously so we're kind of just having
to queue into what we can favorite
weapons so far as trinium verde negative
bird a 93 the rampart was growing on me
and there was one SMG I was using a lot
that I can't remember might be the MX 9
in the cordite to be honest I'm gonna
have to meet that person in a second but
you should pick your class show you this
it doesn't matter in team deathmatch
reach oh yeah you can have multiple of
the same specialists whereas on certain
other more tactical based maps you can
only have one of these specialists do
you think Cod is back I think so but I
feel like Cod never really went away I
mean as much as people wanted oh this is
an old-school map - this is a firing
range right yeah I think people that
stay like it you know it it's dead oops
I guess this was the gun for you man
you don't even have anything on it yet
either crazy damage we'll take it you're
almost at a you are you throwing no
anything and then you decide to get its
bolds and then I see sometimes you play
slower you know I didn't know a firing
range was in this one yeah there's a
bunch of callbacks and I think just like
1415 Maps right off the bat which is I
died in this room so many times
Yeah right like back in the day and I
hate going there sorry Gary I'm sorry if
I missed it
Gary says with no story does the content
justify the price I mean that's gonna be
the big question I think going forward
is $60.00 for basically three different
multiplayer platform the way to say I
don't know three different multiplayer
mode types I know there was when we were
playing blackout previously a lot of
people were like I wish I could just buy
blackout or you know it's hard to say I
generally feel that when I play Call of
Duty I usually have my $60 worth I think
I will dis this time around to just
because I actually liked blackout when I
play he's behind you he's in the trailer
thing or was
oh all right yeah I'm in it so for me uh
Gary yes but obviously you know that's
not for everyone also you know there's
red dad's coming out later this month so
you know not everyone can buy every game
right and we're in the fortunate
position to be able to play a lot of
these big big titles so
crap I'm like I'm liking it I'd probably
buy black out separately yeah Husker
that's a that's a good point but like at
what point would you buy it separately
you know like these are all like
interesting questions is that something
we want like I remember when Starcraft 2
went to three different games to do the
entire thing of Starcraft 2 and I kind
of didn't like that I think ultimately
it was like 124 all three
I think was 40 each instead of like a 60
with like an expansion 420 so we could
be opening up a can of worms that was
like we think you want a multi-million
probably don't might not want down the
road health on huh I don't know what it
was is since you did 200 damage my guess
is that crash popped his alt and gave
him 50 more health at like just the
right time and it almost ultimately you
got him regardless which is good
yeah you gotta do a lot of mini-map
watching yeah I'm not doing that enough
that's why again like with the more
tactical based maps to control maps and
things like that it's a little easier to
just like know your specific role
whereas this is really just like about
kills milling the spawn flipping the
spawns and things like that finding ways
to spawn cameras etc I should pop this
on the phone Dean Ostby don't just waste
bullets remember it's well Chloe whoo
there goes your legs that's a little bit
more graphic than
that called hostile hailstorm inbound
they're coming up this way like yeah
welcome to card man you got to know yeah
easy for me to say because I'm not
playing rush with it though don't worry
we'll swap out next round we'll swap out
well give you a break let you do some
ten finger breathing it'll all be fine
there you go that's a great 9 bang and
you got rid of recons little sonar thing
and the benefit of playing after view is
I get to get body armor that's what I've
been waiting for there's a bunch of I
saw yeah okay so what I've observed from
your gameplay is that yeah yeah yeah no
you're a good mid to long range fighter
so we should just put you in those
situations so you don't have to deal
with these people jumping around and I
know the pooch they destroy the best
voice Batman I'm never mad pretty chill
I mean I'm sure I'm gonna have my
moments like Rob where I'm just like
good assist also it's like learning the
maps again right so day ones always a
little bit more interesting just kind of
relearning the maps or no you have
unlocked body armor which is awesome
it's got it right yeah Daniel I put
myself in a dumb area I just wanted it
oh you slap it slap a noodle oh you guys
give me a break here
also I'm gonna love taking the that's
alright I'm gonna love taking that body
armor from here aided by I almost had
one Katie of one you're just one one eki
aaaah
how do you guys have a access we just
have a physical copy earlier review copy
dark binaries that's how you feel you
definitely don't have to buy the game
you know it's just for the people that
still enjoy playing call of duty I will
I guess continue to level the ICR we're
gonna get some perks on there which is
awesome thank you rob getting some oops
you're welcome no you're welcome yeah oh
we almost got your shotgun though almost
live in the shotgun light fast see what
else you got you got a grip we just got
to keep on walking to get some other
stuff you don't have any of that stuff
and walk yeah we unlocked this stuff
doesn't matter so much yes
I think what I ended up doing at some
point is like I end up taking the second
greed perk and I ended up putting on
like lightweight and cold-blooded I
think my weight is good maybe it was
dexterity you know one of these has like
a good Oh dead silence too is good once
you get them silencer what do you think
review wise asked in well we're not the
reviewers cally plague he's gonna be
reviewing it or review in progress
should be up I think today right that's
what we said 9:00 p.m. so yeah looking
forward to that I'm gonna play but yeah
as you said it's very hard to review
this game interaction when I mean you
could argue most of it is multiplayer
based and it you know it's not out till
tomorrow so that's why we're doing a
review in progress and you can expect a
full review over the weekend so Monday
or Tuesday we'll have our full one yeah
dark finder um that's not totally true I
think that like I had mentioned earlier
the blackout mode is definitely
different from anything that Cod's ever
done granted yes is it in the same space
as a battle royale yeah it is but oh I
don't remember the lemurs or whatever
those were running running across like
that really slow
wait wait on Taylor Harris's reviews and
progress is literally useless I would
disagree
we had a reviewer go to an event and
play like multiplayer and zombies I mean
the only thing blackout was stuff to do
just 100 people and they didn't have a
her people up that the review then but
it you know it's it's helpful and
there's a satellite snapshot it gives
you a snapshot and for people who know
want to know like right before launch
like should they make a call I think
that there is some next benefit of
having that higher that's how you get
assist points too
nice work yeah so that's what you can do
with torque you can kind of like put put
yourself in a good situation i rear I
really liked you would know them the
mode
what's the multiplayer like hardcore
elimination basically like
counter-strike
oh it's called control I think oh that
is peaceful yeah I like that that's fun
we basically buy weapons before each
round oh that might have been oh that's
heist hi that's nice
I think that's heist okay it's basically
yeah it's like Counter Strike where you
actually buy the armor level three arm
it's tight yeah SMG my son is in the
chat hello son Ben's Ben's not wrong we
gotta live that SMG life I'm not living
that SMG life and it's maybe maybe
that's why we're sounds like it's heist
oh okay that was a mistake
don't worry Rob I'm doing worse than you
dude Gold just warming up man I'm just
gonna steal a real gun here
is ground war back or do we have to
stick to 66
I don't think ground wars well you can
do blackout if you want one yeah right
if you want more than I'm for sure
briefing they're easier with I guess I
don't know it's just like snap no I
don't know man you were you're saying
that I like my play style is like longer
range for like I don't know I'm a
shotgun man
I like movement I like to like speed you
maybe I should have gone that some 0 but
depends on the map to right there's a
lot there's a lot more close quarters I
feel like in this one that's just well I
was just saying like that's where I saw
you succeeding yeah oh sure at that
moment right like sometimes you just you
know from me sometimes it's like you
just got slowed down like how you're
playing and you end up making better
better decisions didn't matter because
yeah it's a bad time to iPad ago we did
a UAV I get a UAV on station above so
crash is actually pretty good at like
pretty good at getting points easily
because you got the assault pack which
can help you get kills or me help you
point up yeah that guy's like we're
lagging one or the other and then also
the alt just gets everyone so then that
also helps out obviously
no doubt lights out reload weird grip
like a a que variant where are you going
there nice pick up my tags
UAV established or battle behind me
behind lost advantage my salt pepper
soil not bad now someone I shouldn't
have piece yeah got a hide behind boxes
got a hit camp head glitch yeah we're
definitely fortunate to have the game
early definitely don't want to undersell
that do you have what do you have oh
yeah okay I want one of those guys is SM
cheese Wow another guy in the water
nice iPad me Eric nice play yeah yeah
can't do anything about that
Oh what was that guy was he there the
whole time I'm an idiot he could have
come through that window Oh was he I
don't know I think he came through a
window I
oh oh oh tags tak-tek tags it's like
pac-man gobble gobble
time to run okay miss me well maybe
that's that guy spot oh you're so lucky
like yeah go get him dog can't believe
that guy came back up
we're never gonna get anywhere unless we
actually go and confirm some tags going
out oh oh
go get him dog dog now go dog go get him
go get him talking
yeah dog yeah we'll just we'll just
clean up the dog stuff
it's like we're taking them for a walk
have a leash on my dog on the other side
now the dogs dog might bite the bullet
here they're all this way yeah so recons
really good because of that like the
Widowmaker like mad pack train more boss
all right well I picked it up at some
point like I did take an SMG though Rob
yeah mx9 is still pretty good I have to
say folks the mx9 is still pretty good
look at you
I got there why am I here I should leave
that you got me to the body armor all
right
you're like the hype guy you're like I
am pretty cool huh yeah it's like we're
just gonna be cleaning up the dog stuff
I think that's the line of extreme so
far that yeah well he was getting the
kills I mean we can't dispute that the
dog was putting in work I need a legit
make a mx9 class because clearly that
was working out for us oh we are not
close to anything laughs all right well
we can get that level of I heard this is
really good my friend believes in
acoustic sensor but yeah we all can use
that for now there's what COMSEC is
actually pretty good to you that
basically lets you get your streets
faster do we get to your shotgun yet
maybe maybe that's when you're gonna
really pop off I just need to get to
level eight for you right and then oh
one more level next level I'll get you
your shotgun and that's when big Rob's
gonna shotgun some so it won't go well
but we'll see you know for sure
it was titanfall yeah if you feel like
the same play blackout yeah I would
salton but uh currently no one playing
is there online that split-screen
multiplayer I don't know actually
should we try that would you think I
don't know I mean you want to plug that
in real quick sure see see if that works
what we add so long as you guys don't
mind watching some split-screen so maybe
I should go full camera maybe so that
you can once you hit that PlayStation by
not go full camera we'll put oh oh we're
good yeah yeah so you can log in as
somebody else Oh or did you listen you
just locked me up buddy yeah I totally
did
let's watch I don't know stay there okay
yeah I'll sure whatever we'll just show
them this right or am I gonna log you
back out okay logging eyes log into me
Oh convenient alright so let's try
multiplayer
I'll add controller x2 to join wait dad
dad just do that oh there you go I'm in
yeah yeah min that's me right there in
the back oh except I'm controlling your
thing now oh wait okay that's fine
can I create a class I can't anyway it's
just just find a match we'll see how
this goes
split-screen guys we're gonna try
split-screen I might ditch us so that
you can see both or I'm curious what the
thing looks like I can make a pseudo pip
picture-in-picture depending on how this
shakes out to try to just show you who's
who's who
that's weird we are not doing battle
royale because there are not enough
players people playing because this is a
early copy there were only like nine
people in that you need more than that
so we're trying to do split screen right
now I logged into my account and we'll
see if we can play together or not that
would be pretty cool crop this right
I'll see if this actually works I mean
technically on the screen says that you
can do that right so Cedric asks when's
the review we're gonna have a review
review in progress at 9 p.m. tonight and
then you can expect a full review
Monday Tuesday at the latest when we
have played you know with the servers
officially rocking and everyone playing
because this is such a multiplayer focus
game this time around as there's no
campaign we want to make sure everything
is looking good looking hot like Rob
whoa dude
whoo it's a little hot in here it's
about to get hot damn what's your
opinion so far me of the game says super
chill draw you want to go first I don't
really have much of opinion actually
because I haven't really played all of
it like I haven't seen zombies yet
I've played blackout that seems to be
pretty much the same since the beta
blackout I think is interesting we have
a physical copy of the game that's how
we're doing it I wonder if oh no those
are individuals right okay I always like
curious if it's taking longer because
we're together versus like an individual
which shouldn't be the case but yeah I
have no idea but I don't know I think
I'm most excited for blackout yeah I am
too like that that was fun when we
played it they think it's it's like a
far more approachable Battle Royale
I mean as someone who like I don't know
I'm not that into fortnight I never got
into pub de I don't know I think I think
the that blackout is is less
intimidating in ways where it's like
it's familiar because it's Cod yeah and
we have a review copy that's how we're
playing early we're also trying to the
Swiss screen because you guys were
curious if that would work so hopefully
in a second here we get in a game I'll
move our
cameras kind of once we figure out you
know I'm guessing it's like a top bottom
right yeah so yeah I wouldn't be any
other way yeah yeah if you guys have
questions a blackout 100 player limit
from what we saw Monty is a quads was a
hundred but duo's and solos were 88 from
what you saw yeah yeah start already we
would love to start should we check back
out I don't know that's a great idea
yeah but maybe it's up to you I think
that if you do back out we only try with
the two of us for a brief moment and
then we probably just go back in or we
can just use Abhi's that works too what
do you think Carlos says blackout is an
approachable VR because of Cod's
smooth and polish gameplay I mean I
didn't even there are like a more
familiar experience Carlos so I think
that it'll be easier for people to get
into the only difference is that Cod's
obviously not free whereas like
something like fortnight is which is
probably why it's got so many players on
fortnight cuz even puppy's not free so
but I as I've said in the past I think
there's a lot of players or people that
play cod and I think because there's
such a big user base
I think blackouts gonna work I think it
but time will tell
if I'm right or wrong I guess oh all
right
a brighto brighto Roy hey Rob good good
call on the back out I did that
automatically I didn't even back out
okay well you know what
good call game alright where do you
think you're gonna be and where do you
think I'm gonna be I'm probably gonna be
on top okay
I would imagine all right in fact I'm
willing to bet I'm gonna be on the top
like of the score list that too
what just happened to our game okay
there you go
I am definitely bottom I the gameplay
quality definitely went down quite a bit
oh uh that's fine though I am definitely
on the bottom I am playing crash wait
who are you playing
people also plane crash I think I didn't
even pick it all so we both have to pick
I don't know
wait where's our custom loadout oh I'm
that level five rip rip everything sucks
me yeah alright well it's fine it'll be
fine
whoa dude this is weird is it yeah I
think it's fine the framerate the fact
that you can go to your bodies and do
this dude are you kidding like the
framerate is abysmal right now alright
let's just get through a game okay like
oh it's bad I'm seeing Tan Tock z10 yo I
don't know huh it's okay we might be
better to this I almost had a triple
what well I didn't get it but I
definitely heard a bunch of people
how you doing where you got talk to me
goose yeah what's up support I want I
hit him - yeah see we combo'd him this
is going you know from you him low I
know my oh where was he yet by the
building oh god it's so choppy it's so
choppy it's and keep in mind we're on a
pro man yeah that's true that is a good
point
so definitely playable but would I want
to do this if I didn't have a choice
what the hell that's his area denial was
that dude
if for instance in the handle Oh Lord
there's gotta be our wait you're dead
huh nope oh wait what oh did you kill
that guy that was to kill me I think the
other guy did dude you're slaying all
right jinxiu jinxiu jinxiu that's cool I
want also it's weird that I don't get
your your perks or whatever alright I
made the best out of it you know what
this interests me oh I guess we're
online I wonder what zombies would be
like oh we can do that after this
oh you think zombies would be smoother
maybe I mean if we're playing locally
I'm always trying to look at your screen
to like snap hack a little just like the
old days right Yeah right
oh they're probably all coming oh my god
oh this is not good I'm like one in six
or something and I'm at the top that
can't be right
or is it because we're [ __ ] oh you're so
modest no I'm playing like doodoo that's
why I'm saying like it's not good if I'm
at the top that's not who you want to be
at the top right now
nice way to oh my god the framerate man
oh dude and it's pretty rough it's so
rough like I'm I mean like seriously
it's like kills though man you're
slinging out of your we're on top of our
team right now I'm doing nothing I feel
like I'm just tagging people but I'm not
killing people I'm not picking up tags I
just can't I can't even oh my god it
could also be that I'm playing off the
xsplit monitor which might be slightly
might have like a slight delay compared
to like your screen oh god I'm so sorry
I don't watch the bottom screen right
now guys I'm I'm playing horribly I put
a belt tacking at the fish market
I don't even know if you know where the
fish market is the fish market oh it's
uh down by the pier
gee golly guys oh no I'm at the bottom
now sick sick sick sick sick sick sick
sick this is not my preferred play mode
type I'm really liking this hey you're
doing real well Oh like I was
so you'd want to do that around like
when you notice ones like around a
corner on you or something like
definitely want to get them that way
this guy can't open his nest put his
little little barbed wire up let me help
you rob I had him oh there's a secret
thing yeah oh boy I don't think I've
ever played this bad ever Oh
[Music]
I can't okay this is all I got
oh my god please stop that I think I got
him alright thank you
well things can only go up from here I
feel like I'm playing so bad don't worry
guys I'll pick up tags that's all I'm
good for it oh I'm gonna flame thrower
oh I stopped the guy's a flamethrower
though let's go do it Rob yeah I'll do
it
oh there's a way better I see art no
that guy took it
oh it was you that's a good thing
like I got out of the house are they
still in the billiards room yeah yeah
the stories barricade
so much wipe are you kidding me guy the
window out the window are coming around
it's shooting from the outside
give me your gun oh that's got more
stuff on it did you get him up
don't worry tape me oh goodness oh it
wasn't worth it I was like I got oh my
god oh shoot it spawned me where
everyone is - what's what's my special
find our Burnham burn baby burn
there's a flame um hole there I heard a
lot of screaming looks like Rob found
his new favorite
like they're like I don't know if it's
like a lens flare thing or something but
like the red on some of these character
names is so weird when it's this small
yeah it's crazy lag okay dang it I just
wanted those dog tags sorry that we're
neglecting tattoo if you guys are asking
questions
we're playing split-screen cuz you guys
are curious and asking about it so
that's what we're doing
oh we're a swan and on the side would
camp on this tank come on you want that
tag
oh I had it really getting a top I can
barely see that guy's name I can't see
that guy through the window and I'm
wearing my glasses that's not oh we lost
hey I fixed my score time yeah
fix my score I was playing real bad
robbed like real bad I wonder why
hey look it's back to normal yeah let's
not do that again
no didn't feel I I wasn't feeling it but
you know what it is I think to be honest
I'm just not used to playing
split-screen like since it's been like
how many years since I played a
split-screen game yeah you know yeah but
yeah interesting do you want to try
zombies real quick and then call it a
sort of stream it I think we should yeah
all right let's do it all right what
screen again are we split screening um
or do you want to solo it up why don't
we try splits ok and then we came back
back out at least I'm actually curious
to see how it runs because I think
zombies like oh and all like that is
where which mode do you want to do you
want to do the rush movie that we have
rush
okay so there's rush bottom right or did
you want to read that real quick the
tooltip stuff Oh does it not let you
anyone so the rules have changed all
bets are off this is a whole new ball
game who will be crowned champion in
zombie rush the rule book goes out the
window
you already told me that in test intense
facts action mode
alright let's just try it out see how it
goes and then I can always like back out
of the split screen so that do you want
to do just lets you or you want to
search what people wow what is that what
the hell with those perks revive this is
a lot to take in
oh and then there's elixirs to it looks
like just I mean that's things don't
laboratory what the hell
make some pots Wow no campaign that's
been known for a long time Japan step
the closest thing they have to that
right now is these the specialists
headquarters which gives you a kind of a
sense of the specialist some of them
their backstory how they came to be and
it's also a tutorial so it serves as
both black out split screen question
we're playing split screen right now
just to try it out cuz you guys are
curious yeah oh those are the perks you
choose on the level really that seemed
like oh do I get to pick my stuff oh my
god we're fighting oh we're fighting for
the you know what just do it do what you
want I'll deal with dude I look cool
you're an old man you're an old frail
man hey oh what's this it's a sword
I like this aesthetic to be honest this
was that one where they went back in
time and they had like melee weapons
awaiting textures
um pants up I think and not that it's
one for one but you have to look at it
as they added black out and that was
kind of the trade-off for campaign and
then I also added like more zombie stuff
as well right so wrong
yeah time to run oh we're in the we're
in the glad the arena that's a dead body
or you see it where you see it more you
see oh my god this is all about the
night the night delays right now right
save that damn munition this is good
though yeah it looks pretty good I like
the setting as I mentioned yeah we are
in the arena where they I robbed me
trying to help you and I think it's cool
to have split screen again for the you
know just to have like your friends come
over and play yeah they don't have a
game that's cool right
oh we got to pick up those coins I think
new care I'm gonna got an old-school
revolver well we lost it in Soho
I mean like we don't need it right I
feel like we're playing oh my god
hold on has to be like oh I'm dead I'm
so sorry Rob
I was trying to oh you come back to life
without your lives that's interesting
should I pick up the bomb here gonna do
it by the tip sweet
I don't know if I like this gun that I
bought that you almost bought doors are
open okay so we got to get to that door
again these zombies are very easy oh no
looks like you're really down and I'm
out of ammo
how do you know I'm really down what
what yes ma'am
fine just don't die I guess follow the
gold shinies all right we're defending
this area apparently robbed and then a
poor gob it's like a mystery box oh it
is a mystery box
all right the board's board it up hey
stop that
turn around what oh yeah grenades yeah
what's that over the hammer to build
faster I regret this gun so much bomb
all right oh what a good job Rob we oh
did you get anything good let's see oh
you got a auto pistol you can swap it
shotgun like it that you do you all take
the rampart hey stop we have to go back
hip yeah I go back down let's go back
down yeah yeah it's back oh that's not
good I don't know what kind of blue
zombie that is but is most giving me
anxiety if it's that big so quickly
there's a poison Oh drop some point Lu
insuk Ellis wait yeah but we're supposed
to go down or something what it says
right get to the pit in 43 seconds how
do we get to the pit cat downstairs I
said down is it this way where were we
and yeah yeah we're gonna go we're good
we didn't we didn't oh I think we're
good oh yeah it's this way there's an MX
9 if you want that it's also a bunch of
mystery boxes
I can't romantic
zombi ruff Oh what do you see what do
you see goose uh-oh oh I'm in a bad area
oh whoa you can't get out nope I died
that the hard way don't worry I'm back
there's a zombie that's on fire okay I
go them oh I'm dead dead now so you okay
oh bottom left shows you how many hearts
I didn't realize that all right well
that was my bad that's poorly played on
my part you are clearly the better
zombie player all right you got the
hammer you can wreck it Ralph oh you
don't want to be here
oh I had it lick sir that entire time I
couldn't see because of my microphone
what's up my dude love your stream first
time watching things I haven't thanks
appreciate it four areas for mini-bosses
as RT oh cool thanks Rob is just running
in circles that's what you guys doing
zombies what you guys do hi oh yeah sure
life can I steal that extra life if
that's not ammo if this was truly a
co-op experience I should be able to
steal a life from me it's a kill that's
good you don't have any bullets buy a
new gun we're keep going and win it
right there Street fire yep all right so
it doesn't appear that even though he
beats the round that I comeback just
unfortunate that's okay
you got to find the next you got to do
temple now which is that that way and
down yeah always run for ammo yeah sucks
the swordfish from zombies yeah all
right don't be soft here out yeah all
right I don't fight so I come across
like I had
oh I done goofed you got there two times
Oh big dudes coming somewhere
oh you say that now in Japan saying that
you want them to do separate
single-player multiplayer and then
everyone's just gonna complain that we
didn't have the multiplayer and all that
stuff so I think it's worse that way
oh the marauders right behind ya
I don't know what your investors do Rob
but you can dpad some of them I have no
idea what they do though
alright oh no I'm back up here head scan
headshots have a chance to insta kill
that's good oh god that's a big guy okay
oh we got a nuke there that was awesome
that was like perfect timing like that
was clutch how come you guys can play
now last warning
oh we have a review copy so we have a
physical copy it's a big boy he's a big
boy I mean if anything a lot of people
are just saying they wish they had the
Battle Royale is a separate thing and I
could see that already
you know this guy's hella Dom kisser
what did you say this game doesn't have
a campaign mode no it does not have a
traditional campaign mode the closest
thing they have is to specialists HQ as
I mentioned earlier which is basically
like backstories for certain specialists
and then also a tutorial
nice work Rob big plays what happened in
the melee weapon for Tommy it could be
because we're playing the rush mode
which is not being at this like
traditional zombie mode you fire it back
up a mate
okay yeah looks like he might be back
somewhere follow the coins they'll never
lie to you
well you could just ditch the swordfish
now if you want oh look a little voodoo
doll thing so great
oh-ho the frame rate sweet frame rate no
it's what the hell little Goblin oh geez
whoa
exploded - yeah it looked like he went
in a like melee to go
360noscope
oh oh that guy is a gladiator looking
dude myself instead alright it's okay
it's okay two more lives maybe you'll
get another nuke my ammo box is good
yeah that guy's being a big dumb boy as
Rob the sake get them are no call that
Goblin
yeah he's jumping around and killing
them
he's jumping around and clanking them on
the head that's actually really cool
yeah because I died that's why we're
here still good one life to live baby
we'll do things to kill over there later
no I think it would I think maybe one
more yeah last one last one last no oh I
don't know what that guys doing though
that guy must be bugged oh maybe not
he woke up I'll be really dope if he
dropped out axe or something there
yeah holds them down I feel robbed I
don't know I felt I feel like I'm high
it's just like chaos I rush completed Oh
Tigers Tigers yeah I think you're going
my way all right good luck this is what
the Emperor will do when you are trying
to take over his reign as the emperor oh
it's just dogs
Tigers no I know I know but I think it's
more intimidating than a dog yeah it's
not available digitally yet
oh good try good try good try good try
you definitely spit everywhere no you
definitely held us help us go there i I
just didn't know what I was doing uh do
you want to try the tradition sure time
for that I guess we do you sure you want
to do it by yourself
sure okay maybe I can back out what's
like once we get back here
dude those Tigers are scary they were
very fast yes battlecry all right let's
see if I can back out here let you do
the do the good stuff let's see what
happens hey what hey boo me no well
maybe it's thinking about it because
it's thinking oh and I guess I don't
progress which makes sense yeah are you
you're out now okay yes hey guys playing
online no we're not I mean it's still
online but it was just us two there all
right let me fix our picture picture so
that we are combining the package and
while I do that we'll just go full game
okay so
what should i do I don't know zombies
that well oh I think you can pick
whatever I think maybe play IX just
because that has the I think that has
potential for melee weapons unless you
guys want to see the other one that was
a zombie rush mode and that was just a
it is a a kind of like simplified
version
Patrick Rossi so that wasn't what this
the the actual legitimate zombie mode is
is like waiting for other players yeah
you're searching in a lobby I think you
have to make a private match if you want
to just play by yourself I mean whatever
I'll play someone else all right that is
you can split screen black vernon's
that's why we were trying it a couple of
y'all asked about if we could do split
screen so we said cache traffic wants to
know did Rob win Rob always wins
catastrophic it doesn't matter what
we're playing he always wins this one
says players crisis play as the crisis
guy don't know what is that in our
rankings
oh don't know god I hate this you I you
how dare you so long I feel like I'm
like that's like I select the class so
you can be the Guardian or whatever the
rule that looks cool paired chuckles so
do you want to be the tempest yes
you solidify that are you now The
Tempest
give back out of that are you the
tempest
yeah cool all right all right go listen
ready up we are off split-screen oh
we're hard best weapon is start out with
at launch it depends what you want to
play Zach it seems like SMGs are quite
still really strong
okay you guys are starting
so this is one of the two zombies that
you can get into No oh wow all my ice
melted it's cuz it's hot as balls in
this room yes but not as bad as it used
to be you have to agree with that yeah
this this new fan that's more silent
majority I feel it yeah you feel it yeah
that was the point
all right I believe that you can play
blackout in split-screen yeah I wouldn't
be shocked because we could play
multiplayer split-screen the framerate
was kind of a little old okay you've
done stolen others
maybe or we get by mysterious voices the
cave was not such a smell idea
singleplayer you get the vo now what up
Turco Bango Turco bangle for the win
I like this like this you know turquo
Bango is the dumbest name boo PSN name
change bro yeah next year
yeah well still better than nothing ffs
get the fan on hot Rob quick says MuRF
Rio he already pointed it towards
himself sorry rip headphone users why
did you get a third person Oh sir who
are you calling oh you could just be
loading in totally be loading you have
to be so now you actually have to open
the doors like well zombie rush was just
like wave days
we will defeat their board then I will
find the man in the mask Oh daddy had a
melee weapon ready
hi he's had his little [ __ ] I'm gonna
steal Rob cat before Rob can get it oh
that's oh said that catastrophic whoa
who that is - I think now I figured it
out yeah that's not cool man
that's not cool it's not cool
I'll just take captain daddy then what
that's fine I actually don't want that
it was Chris waters that
oh there's fire pyrotechnics you
wouldn't take that Oh get up adrenaline
shot oh that's a fire you know it's
because of these jackasses yo I saved
your life saved my life
right before ya know at some point
someone's got to open a door right
Vina I guess you're attracted to cat
mancom she ain't the only one commenting
that's true
she isn't I'm pretty sure well it's
probably the first time I read your
comment I've read a bunch of other ones
even that more fry one that Japan steps
just upset I think about God so that's
the thing
Oh heart wall saves no one yeah he only
gets saved cat man is catastrophic I
think is what he use shortening acronym
poor lucky man that'd be a good PSN name
alright so I guess all of them want to
open the door please
1000 Dolores is the frame rate better
since beta oh I think in single-player
it's better I mean sorry
non non split screen
you might wanna get some in says bread
lark you got a new gun same thing got
the escargot
I can't blocking one of the points huh
yes I can move us and as you not like in
Diego yo this feels like a dead end
let's not be in here alright we are now
hopefully not blocking the scores yep
yeah I know but I'm not gonna say that
is Leslie lies and I feel in the fire
animation that's fair
Oh apparently catastrophic pays me to
read comments that's that could also do
pay me I'll read more comments it's what
it is Japan Steph look at the bottom
right well he's on the Welling now but
the other gun was definitely the
escargot Rob he switched to it so I'm
not a liar see that's a scar go right
that's what sucks
escargot eschar got a scar cops the
effing snail yes
yo this shotgun was a bad idea oh-oh
that's a tiger can't really say oh oh
you got rid of that tiger that demon
tiger I've never really eaten it how do
we have it oh we have review copy got to
k2 this game is on crack only detract
from this such a dumb this is a dumb
game
apparently I'm getting $2 67 cents per
stream pretty good pretty good with that
I can get Oh what right oh so there's
like before oh boy what's the Marauder
what are you doing sleeping oh I can't
get you high you get them this is good
distraction tactics rather this shotgun
sucks
is their juggernaut in zombies oh yeah
it just looks every because it was I
suggest everyone who is like dang like
that Pro building a barrier no look is
this game fully out ask Carter Bob for
some people yes
not everyone what is this what does this
do time slip what is that what is that I
don't even know what it means
forget it uh I don't know Japan I
actually have played cod primarily on
content so that's what I'm used to I'm
sure people with nothing I've seen
shroud do some crazy things something
else a keyboard that I don't think you
could ever do on console so the probably
feels better in that regard for sure
Zak see best gonna start with I think if
you just go mx9 and multiplayer and then
kind of slowly get through the smg's
it's pretty good unless you like assault
rifles in which case just play the way
you want see just watching an earlier
stream there's a dude level 45 an hour
after servers went live really uh well
technically we had the coffee last night
and so we could have been playing as of
last night
whenever the server's went live I know
that we were allowed to stream as of 6
a.m. so it's not impossible to think
that someone could be 45 but they
definitely probably like no no sleep
date or something yeah mystery box is
down how do I use time slip I don't know
if I use it I use it what's that what
does that do if you guys have played
blackout do you know he can compare to
identify the weapons before picking up
we have anything able to play blackout
on the full retail version because
there's just not enough people
populating it right now so I wouldn't be
able to tell you outside of like what we
play through beta Ryan and I don't think
that was the thing
betta right which is probably why you're
asking nobody put the system in the
description that's fair hiko hikiko
coming I will put it in there for plan -
can you not do that to people Rob we are
playing on a ps4 Pro I am toast let's
play the beta on this screen still have
not convinced me to buy the game first
but I haven't bought and launching the
first game I mean sometimes you get
fatigued right like if you're not
interested in playing and you know for
me a lot of my friends are really what's
kind of gonna motivate me to play if
those guys are falling off or those gals
are falling off it makes sense
you should play what you guys want to
play if you've fallen off the train you
fallen off the train it can be a thing
I am not done all right bTW it's so good
for switch I got that time slim I don't
know how to use it is that it is that a
passive ability might be one of those we
literally what you have on there right
the thief had stuff I mean I use them
all
oh the top one why just use another one
he's behind you
well was in front of you oh oh no I'm in
I'm in a little bit of a pickle here
Oh No
what's that debuggers bonus point oh you
got tight I thought I could jump over
that you're crazy
where are my friends we're doing not bad
we're at a 10 right now
Oh some says I have to find the others
later cat thanks for setting mine did
you guys start with zombies when you got
the game or did you play multiplayer
blackouts as Zach Mons today we started
off with a bit of just traditional
multiplayer some Kill Confirmed TDM
moved along to zombies to show that a
split-screen rush no just now Rob is in
a multiplayer zombies map more
traditional zombies not rest mode
blackout is not being populated well
enough right now so we can't get into it
properly
my guess is closer to 9 o'clock tonight
when the game comes out proper you'll
probably see more
and thank you guys all for stopping by
watching chat and hanging out we do
appreciate it
we're live every day at alerts are every
Monday to Friday at 11 a.m. if you
haven't subbed
consider it just so you guys get
notified as to when we go live so we can
continue to hang out and shag and all
that fun stuff can you run a hardcore
match probably won't have time today
Carlos probably going to end the stream
after this zombie map but tomorrow I
know that Ben and John Luke will be back
with community Fridays where we play
games or they play games with you folks
out there that want to play games with
us
and I think it's gonna be Call of Duty
tomorrow again but blackout hopefully
these servers are more populated by then
which I imagine they will be so if
you're looking forward to that I believe
check that out
but yeah oh you know what I have is like
my special weapon okay oh the l1 r1 yeah
chakram please play Book of the Dead
I've been watching the whole two hours
as energy gamer @yt I mean would you
really want us to just hop in and see it
and not really get through the rounds we
can potentially do that but come on dude
I mean maybe if we die here we just
think you think
[Music]
while I use it maybe not that was a
melee weapon he chose earlier as a class
and you can pick yeah I think the class
was Tempest and the items that he had or
the weapon that he had there was the
chakram one that he didn't throw him
when I came away with yeah played blood
of the ground okay next time he died Rob
just swallow peace resolve the other do
you live Oh someone wants after they
want to see the other zombie mode or I
don't know if it's a mode necessarily
it's just another like alright story I'm
saying I should quit I don't know I
don't I feel bad for these people but I
mean if that's what role that I gotta
pee
it's going to be us go spell undo the
Titan oh this is the Titan
Oh
that's been a stable
like recoil yeah yeah I mean a lot of
guns are still oh nice max ammo great
timing
all right you hear level six
it's the mob of the dead BT's please
play we'll try it
show campaign there ain't no campaign
the only thing like I mentioned earlier
is these specialist headquarters which
does give you a taste of the background
stories for the specialist and then also
gives you tutorials on how to play them
and multiplayer just let us die just
bleed out Rob yeah yeah little help me
look eater action there it's cold it's
cold guys running for his life team is
getting murdered up in the tower yeah
don't do it there's tigers on you
save yourself argh wall underscore n
this works out though Rob what okay now
back out peace we're gonna go check out
that other game game-mode zombies mode
that you guys want to see by asking
about campaign by people they're
trolling me and you answer them uh yeah
but some people might actually just not
be but no give me people benefit of the
doubt what's what are we talking about
here Book of the Dead was one of the
Dead is what they're saying a lot of the
Dead blood of the Dead there it is
I've had it scroll yep oh it's hardcore
all right let's do it solo match yeah
let's do it
make it quick and snappy every day
select I live lass every day I'm
hardcore oh you don't even need a
selected class that's how much of a bad
a you are that's fine it's fine whatever
this is what they want
you give us the fire oh so this is the
more story focus zombies I guess not
speaks easytek I didn't mean the real
thing
gentlemen VI yeah
you should be closer to the lab no
matter is this way if you please
[Music]
you're late
[Music]
dr. dr. is there a planet melodious
you'll be needing this the preneur
already ready
read it again what Sabine I'm pebbles
they just changed our let me guess
you're not gonna let us in on what that
was about
what explain why you have people in
freezer no time to explain
these guys are like if you were a hacker
I CPU usage
[Applause]
Oh sancisco oh it's the Alcatraz I was
hearing with this there's an Alcatraz
map that's what we're on got it so cool
you are you up to speed on the story
yeah I know I am Jon week
let's do this Rob Marx's topic edgewood
this may be just another delusion must
be surely I would never lead myself into
such a about my issues its intimacy hi
how are you oh wow you actually like
build the concrete deck it's not like oh
really
it's not like would my god you're right
top box that damn it it would sink yes
this looks bad but something can be
aircrafts as dansgame anything
[Laughter]
[Music]
this looks good I mean this is one of
multiple scenarios that you could go
through and Zombies I know a lot of
players are going through zombies right
now I can build a particle accelerator
from scratch but I can't
one straight captain farkles as crime is
mentioned we just have a review that's
why we're so so warden of Alcatraz
finally realsies
that's right yeah what I knew who you
were all alone dressen's happy
Guardsman's disguise I'll not allow some
incorporeal third-rate occultist to get
the best of me how's that how you tell
yeah sorry I'm so used to blackout that
would be where these zombies would be
I'm right okay seven what have you ready
to be blue barely can afford it hope we
get it tight
I app it was infected
I had to amputate you don't have enough
money right now hey some more kills
you'll get there it's a little less
stressful I feel like by yourself well
this is like your class Yahtzee daddy
like take the box we can say whatever we
want about the game be honest because
we're not the ones reviewing it so you
know take our personal opinions with a
grain of salt I'm excited for it cuz I
just I generally enjoy cod and I like
black out it gives me this happy median
of not building in fortnight but also
having like the shooting mechanics that
I have known for like a long time I'm
not a huge Dom B's man personally am i
with you guys that blackout could have
been potentially something on its own
maybe I don't know what you would do for
the rest of the odd multiples out those
I don't know how you package that like I
wouldn't say there's anything
game-changing outside of like the
blackout stuff though I mean they've
always been good at zombies are giving
you more zombie stuff up front it is
unfortunate that there is no campaign
but what are you gonna say sorry I
totally thought that's a sniper yeah
like I'll play blackout my only question
is like just you know yeah I think I
know the answer that question oh you
really love not opening doors huh you
don't want that although I shouldn't be
the one telling you what you want
[Music]
that's not nice I mean yes 490 is a free
game that you know a lot of younger a
lot of the younger generation are
gravitating towards it is great it is on
multiple platforms
you know it's hard like when you go to
school and like you have a couple kids
talking about like oh dude I played for
tonight last night got this got that
like as another child that's going that
school it's hard not to play that game
right I mean I definitely and maybe even
Rob can speak to this we definitely live
in a different era like we were more
the n64 of the world the genesis is you
know at some point Xbox like more local
experiences now it's like kids can play
with each other from like their homes
like you know their parents are probably
giving them their mobile like like
either their phone or iPads like here's
a good example right I was getting on a
flight last week to San Diego and there
was two kids behind me in line with you
know their family and they were both
playing for at night on iPads yeah and
I'm just like this is what it is like
I've never seen it out in the public I
kind of always knew that was the case
yeah but it's a reality you know like
crazy how do I place as Collin well I
think in about eight hours a little less
than eight hours you should be able to
play if you buy the game Hey Dude Love
the game play says has name has nine
thank you for you're the kind where it's
appreciated yes Thank You hikiko commie
for telling people that we are on a ps4
Pro blackout is the new for tonight
we'll see box night.i again there is a
big user base or player base for COD but
again it's not free like fortnight is so
I don't know how big blackout will be
that again
not clearly it's time for some
digression Rob instead of this mystery
box backseat game
oh yeah do a wheel but I get what
happens I don't know what the hell was
that
how's the lag latency went online stood
it was spine and multiplayer earlier
there were a few people that are you
know that are just gonna lag a little
bit on here on your multi players well
in terms of zombies I think he played
one match with other folks it seemed
fine nothing yet but there was one guy
that was kind of like warping on me and
that's all me warping not the right word
but he definitely he or she was
definitely kind of like flagging on the
map that sounds ominous
black out is just like pub G yeah it's
probably more like Poggi but a little
bit more Katy right cuz like not so much
bullet drop and stuff like that open a
door says you've got mail hai hai hai
hai hai hai open a door okay I need to
turn the power on first
I'm a little new to this map yep
please open nice work whoa this place
looks creepy I don't know what I should
do okay dang it dang it oh that would be
a new areas Wow
this is that gun that you won the Battle
Royale for us with the auger yeah I like
it yeah that's pretty good
yeah well I mean this is an area we
didn't explore yet that's a cafeteria
east side power to use that a lot to
this and open the door yeah oh I'm back
all right so you got shortcut so we got
to try to unlock the power somehow power
power power power what's this power
oh Linda bye nice work Rob
this isn't good like I was wondering
bata says prime yeah what do you think
about black out we had a lot of fun with
it first yeah I like it that's like the
only oh [ __ ] yeah so we would play in
the office we squat it up we got a
couple wins I think as a squad now it's
fun yeah well I mean we enjoyed it sure
what is that he's walking on fire oh my
god there's something like a possessed
doll hi baby
you good boy today oh crap that's cool
nice round 9
artyom is a power of Samaria
maybe that capo or is that this way yeah
I don't know if it was I don't know if
you got the power
it's just side power right yeah darn
whoa let's go find that okay oh dang
just a hellhound no problem that's over
there how many maps a Shawn are we
talking about like more traditional
multiplayer or we zombies like what do
we go dude these guns are legit I know I
wish I could have these forever king and
country
oh don't forget that you have the l1 r1
later too like you have these like shot
battle things that like let you ground
pound a bunch I believe uh hi oh look at
legendary how are you doing hello
Treecko hello Oscar
feed it it's part of the class how do we
feed it energy crap it's no problem well
you could use your alt if you want oh
oh yeah baby
bring it Wow I like this a lot maybe I
shouldn't have told you to use it there
because yeah it's already kind of ran
its course oh you got through the round
though kill zombies in front of the
hellhound is what everyone's saying okay
Thank You captain assist as well as
energy for that one my zombie manners
uh-oh
I'll let check correct me but I saw
three is it like the X the voyager of
despair and then also this one the Book
of the Dead where was the blood of the
Dead yeah he's sucking it in I think
yeah yeah yeah this is good you can also
activate those traps taxi gaming sorry
guys no idea where all the elixirs
three maps and zombies thanks time
top-25 spice guy keep doing it it's
basically soul blocks yeah I think you
just gotta do it near hit the nearest
yeah I saw it the old run in a circle oh
my god this is not good
oh yeah I'm doing work this guy's
shaking you got like a little police
baton to a key or four part all right
that happened so let's keep beating that
hound six zombies to the dog six zombie
should feed the dog I feel like we did
at least six
hello Benoit
they're gonna be great hoppers this week
Kevin asks so we because this month has
been so hectic with releases and stuff
going on we we're gonna pause on grape
hoppers until like November mid-november
we'll bring it back thanks for asking
though
oh you have like a last scan or
something that's interesting
good try good try good try good try
thank you guys for the tips
there should be three hounds makes sense
thank you for the tips again we
appreciate it yeah so thanks for out for
playing that was kind of like um play
most of this stuff we just didn't get to
blackout because as we had mentioned we
have it a little early not everyone has
it yet so those blackout rooms aren't
really being populated yet but I was
soon by tonight / tomorrow they're gonna
be way more filled played zombies rush
mode we did the zombies IX or nine
mm-hmm a lot of zombies there zombies
there we did look at the dead thank you
for that shout out there to do that so
glad we got to do that did our
traditional cod multiplayer we did some
split-screen stuff too because y'all
were curious yeah we did Ally but we'll
be back tomorrow or John Luke and Ben
will be to play some more Call of Duty
probably definitely playing blackout
yeah and yeah we're just playing because
we review copy what are your thoughts
Rob anything
my thoughts are and from playing beta
and stuff yeah I don't know I've never
like I've always I've fallen off of cod
I don't know if this is necessarily
gonna bring me back but that blackout
would be the only thing yeah that like I
I would have a reason to purchase this
personally yeah makes sense but yeah I
don't know zombies I even fell off that
was always fun to do split-screen like
growing up but I don't know if I'll I
don't know if that will bring me back to
this yeah I mean even for me like I
didn't like he said I didn't personally
play zombies even so I've never been
into zombies but I do like cod
multiplayer I do like what they're doing
the specialist especially on some of the
more tactical modes where you actually
can see the use of like a torque where
the barbed wire and stuff like that area
denial it comes into play more than your
TDM Kill Confirmed yeah and then yeah
definitely blackout it sure it's of all
the battle Royales personally that's
this is the one that feels the most for
me for sure just because you know cod
multiplayer makes a lot of sense to me
because we played it for so many years
and then it's nope there's no building
you know and I don't have to deal with
bullet drop and stuff like that so it's
fun for me but yeah it sounds like fun
for you as well so come back tomorrow of
course and stay tuned again spot for
that review in progress I think later
today tonight and yeah and then the the
actual final review once Callie's had a
time had her time to really test out the
servers make sure everything's
functioning the way it should and yeah
it's pretty sweet thanks every star to
nning in until next time see y'all later